i mean it was kind of your stunt
it was totally my stunt and i had
reached out to you this was where i
jumped off the port-a-potty
and you were there and i shattered my
ankle i mean i had 11 screws in my ankle
it was uh
as far as like surgery and screws it was
the worst injury i've ever had
um which is fitting because i was there
for your worst injury you ever had
oh yeah that's right wow um i did yeah i
did the loot for
wild boys and came crashing down and
broke my pelvis my thumb cracked my
skull that was like a heavy concussion
huh
uh yeah yeah that was uh that one was
pretty heavy i i don't i woke up
i mean you know when you get concussed
there's a moment when you remember
coming too truly even though you're
talking and whatever but right
it was so it was so upsetting i remember
you uh they were loading you onto a
stretcher and and you were saying like
don't let my kids see this something
like that it was really
really do you remember saying that uh i
think that's around the time i started
coming too
yeah because i remembered the stretcher
i think that what woke me up was the
pain
of getting on the stretcher and i was
like
something's wrong with my hip that's the
first thing i said and i remember the
guy looking at me and said well that's
right
like you're it's okay you're fine did
they show that on wild boys
so they saved all the footage and then
later on mtv had their um
show about injuries scarred yeah right
and then they reached out to tremaine
and said hey can we get
this footage and tremaine reached out to
me and he said i just want to make sure
you're cool with this
because they're asking me and that's
where it was i mean
this was this was like a really
sensitive and
and heavy thing because tony hawk
like has always been the ambassador of
skateboarding and really like
you know representing like safety you
know like
i don't want to say but but for you to
be not wearing a helmet was
was it was a big deal and the the whole
idea with the wild boys doing the loop
was oh well we gotta have you in this
chimpanzee suit tony
you know you gotta be wearing a
chimpanzee suit you can't really fit a
helmet into the
yeah but that was so there's a few
things with that i mean if you want to
get into the weeds on it
uh bob and i were doing this doubles
routine
bob burn questions that was on the boom
boom hug jam too
so well this you were shooting
literally three days after we ended
about a six-week run
of tourists we had just flown home from
florida right the tour was over
we had been doing my loop every night on
the tour so for 30 shows
right right but now we're at bob
bernquist house and this is a loop that
was made out of wood but here's the
thing
we bob and i didn't intend to do that
we just did our doubles routine right
and that we had
we knew from huck jam and like that was
cool and then jermaine looked over right
now i said i was like hey monkey loop
and
bob's like yeah and i remember thinking
like
maybe i don't know if that's a good idea
but
but we had we were so caught i was so
cocky about
the loop that we had been doing that i
was like we got this and then i remember
bob went down first and he bailed and i
really should have
saw that as a warning sign because bob
on his own lube right right it was like
waterlogged made out of wood
like you guys know it was trap it was
that was the problem the problem was
like we couldn't get the right amount of
speed
and then when on my second attempt i did
mistake number one which is
pump through the transition because i
was trying to
i was trying to compensate for lack of
speed and that's like the first thing
you tell anyone that's going to
loop do not pop through the transition
and here i am
like then i just did it and i remember
like oh whoops
yeah and then you don't remember
anything else until you came too yeah
until they were loaded in the ambulance
yeah i mean
like he okay tony came out of the loop
at midnight like on like a sideways
corkscrew
kind of a a thing and like
i remember it like it's midnight to to
like six
you know like just vertical drop down
and like landed on the flat there
and uh i remember it looking more like
you hit your head on the flat than than
your hip
but i think it was all once yeah oh it
was the most it was the most brutal
brutal and you were there i was there
yeah
i was in a a i remember when i finally
saw the footage and i remember thinking
like they had two girls in bikinis
standing right there like i landed right
in front of them
and then him and pontius and all you
hear is tremaine going medic
yes yes that was the that was the worst
i love tony hawk and he's raising money
to build skate parks by selling a
limited number
of these hand signed legendary
photos and there's a link in the bio to
get one
so help tony hawk build skate parks
okay buy a hand signed
freaking print yeah dude
yeah dude